Let's Help answer that question let's
ask Colonel Doug McGregor a retired U.S
army colonel and he joins us now Colonel
great to see you this evening just a
whirlwind Whiplash of news today when it
comes to Russia and Ukraine what should
we make of it
well not quite what Senator Graham had
to say or for that matter President
Biden
the destruction of the pipeline was
clearly not executed by Russia No One
Believes that in fact the German
population has been polled and
overwhelmingly is opposed to the notion
of any war with Russia and dismisses out
of hand the notion that the Russians are
responsible for the pipeline
I think three things are what we're
dealing with right now first of all
pujin has decided that no one in
Washington will negotiate with him and
he knows that Washington is ultimately
in control and so he's decided that in
response he's got to escalate the
military operation people aren't aware
of it in the west but the Russian forces
in Ukraine have always been outnumbered
from the day they entered Ukraine
that's going to change rather
dramatically and I suspect the bombers
that she referred to who carry both
conventional or nuclear weapons will
have conventional arms and those bombers
are probably going to be used in the
escalation that we're about to witness
in Ukraine and I think he's going to
settle this dispute in Ukraine on terms
that are acceptable to Russia that we
may not like
but other than Poland no one in NATO is
interested in going to war with Russia
if we persist on this line we will see
NATO just dissolve and fragment
because they will assume you're saying
they will not follow Poland's lead not
stand together as I assume that's what
you're saying colonel
of course absolutely no one wants to go
to war with Russia other than the polls
and a few people in Washington D.C
well that will be the key that will be
the key whether or not if the world will
not follow the Poland into war with
Russia will in fact the leaders of the
United States of America push the world
into war with Russia Colonel Doug
McGregor always great to hear from you
thank you so much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight